that's an issue they're not dropping
their knickers because my like a third
of mana's version but they're dropping
their knickers more than me drop hankies
no my my my only
it's time as like as a woman like you've
really showed effort to show a man that
you appreciate him and you're interested
I know you do you do what I'm saying
like um go ahead go ahead sorry I'm not
going um I was gonna say so
you know you guys are speaking about
this
what do you think of someone who's been
in a relationship in a long relationship
like I'll give an example
um I've been with my partner for like a
year and a half now and the other day I
said Tim we like to do date nights we
like to keep it spicy and we have a
child right it's not his child but he he
takes on the role brilliantly love that
yeah and I said to him
um Monday night you're booked date night
meet me at this hotel I've booked the
hotel I've filled it with balloons
petals everything
um and and I did that for him so what
what do you think of that like I'm
treating him no but on the flip side you
fight sometimes so but you know
something right that would work for you
uh-huh and if it works for you that's
great I appreciate that but that
wouldn't work for me
so something totally different like for
you booking a hotel and that I don't
like hotels I'm fussy about my food I
hate flowers okay so just call you the
date night but then you you pick
whatever you want there's nothing wrong
in that yeah but the thing is is that
sometimes don't even tell him surprise
surprise him yeah yeah surprise him yeah
he doesn't need to be told no he wasn't
told he was just told he was given an
address but also he's given an address
and be there at 6am nothing can I just
say something interesting that I've
observed um because I've given this
example a lot and whenever like women
say the thing that they did for their
boyfriend or their husband or whatever
it was it's always something that like
women would enjoy yeah
yeah I don't I don't know him maybe this
was like you know I'm sure he
appreciated either way but it's just
interesting like I think a lot of times
we look through our point of view and
not there but you know what you just
reminded me of something it's Pearl is
so right when she said that because
remember I said that that wouldn't work
for me but
what actually worked for me was
Christmas
I said you know what because we don't
live together because I'm my mom's
caregiver so it's impossible because of
the way I am because my mom's got
Dimensions she's really Sublime so I
look after my mum so hence the two
separate houses but I said you're going
to spend Christmas
and I'd planned it so that I hate movies
and he's a nerd he loves movies The Only
We Love alcohol
and we love good food
and it was Christmas my birthday is this
after Christmas and he had such a
relaxing time
I forgot my birthday
and I only remembered my birthday my
birthday was in December
and we only we didn't have Christmas
dinner
we realized that I think the new year
was like what happened to Christmas
dinner and I still standing in the
fridge you know because we ate and we
snapped and to him he loved that yeah
but for me to go and do something that I
mean I was sat down there when I'm
watching the movie marathon I hate
movies but that is something that he
enjoys because the thing is that in
relationships I always say that we
always think about what we want but we
never think about what we can give can I
can I say one thing I feel like um and
this is my opinion I feel like there's
one part of it where all you women are
for getting right
um when men are
going out the way to give you stuff or
do some surprise for y'all the one for
y'all keep forgetting just one important
thing that we want our back too but we
don't like to say I mean y'all always
say the word fangs or you won't give us
a team but we like it back you know what
I'm saying like it's always us men going
our way to do stuff for the women to get
you know I mean but we don't we don't
get it back you don't give it to receive
that's right I'm just saying like like
we love it like you see how we do some
surprise things or we take you out we
like it back and that's why I said I
think the point they're trying to make
um and I I agree with you I don't think
you should give so you should can
receive but I think a lot of men just
feel like women put in no effort
nowadays yes
100 I think what it means is that the
men put in too much effort now probably
because you know what right all the
things that he's saying everyone to say
to my man oh yeah I want you to book a
hotel I guess we're gonna go you're
gonna explain it on your own because
that is not my that's too much
do you know what I mean I'm happy with
him if I come to his house and there is
curry go and rice and salad
yeah I'm in heaven that's that's it for
me I was gonna say I mean that's it for
me the society the the societal
narrative in there that men are
constantly told that we're dispensable
and that our time and energy doesn't
mean anything so when I coach when I
coach guys right because I do date
coaching on the side now it's the first
step is always to help them to
understand that like you have value bro
like like guys just have this idea that
like oh it's pick up Artistry so I'm
going to read this book and learn these
patterns and do this and then when she
does this I'm going to do this and I'm
thinking Bro you've forgot one thing
self-respect you haven't even judged
this person like these some of these
guys who are new to The Dating Game
often go into clubs and they give their
time and attention to People based on
looks and I'm standing there thinking I
can tell this one's got a boyfriend this
one's just for attention this one's
emotionally available actually likes the
other guy at the back of the room but
it's talking to you because you got game
but she's gonna waste your time later
modern guys have been so brainwashed and
told to be emotional and feminine and
like your time doesn't mean anything you
should be you should be lucky to have
any woman around you that they waste
their time and energy do you know the
one thing that my black guys do the one
thing that I find that modern guys do
which
no what modern guys don't do which my
man does regular is telling me the truth
whether I like it or not thank you you
can't do that in this game no no you
can't no no you can tell me whether I
like it or not 100 I agree and I think
that you need to and sometimes I it's
all right
I can't say that you don't care about my
feelings but he will my man will tell me
the truth whether and it's not like I
know how we fit what kind of truths
everything anything bro everything
listen right you know a fact you look
fat look at your face you know like
you've got two bits of never hanging
down if you did that now he'll be he'll
be in jail for emotional abuse he'll be
on some blog so so auntie I I agree with
you like I I think a lot of men are
afraid to tell women the truth and I
think more women would respect it if
they did but at the same but at the same
time
um modern women I think on some level
like to be lied to and don't want the
truth and they want to be sold a fairy
tale because we've been told our whole
lives were Queens princesses and tens I
realized that because I heard everybody
talking about this lizzo certainly so
and I saw lizzo for the first time
last this week
uh big she's
and I just thought to myself when I had
always talk about lizzo and I just
thought wow is that is that is that her
and I was just surprised that all the
yeah but there are no but there are no
standards for women right so lizzo can
can kind of have a physique that is not
as in line with what we generally
consider fit healthy attractive and
flaunt it in this like you know over
over kind of zealous way but men will be
scrutinized for like Leonardo DiCaprio
be scrutinized for dating like a 25 year
old even though he's a grown man that's
a grown woman yeah so I had no problem
with
her her size
which wants to be fat that's a business
I hope she stays healthy I but
me personally I'm skinny and I wouldn't
wear what she's wearing but what what I
found out
till he shocked me is that as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible